hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i'm right now doing some youtube
videos to pass the knowledge guys
show you how pro traders are actually
working share with you my experience
show you the different tools i like to
use for technical analysis but as well
how i use the different market dynamics
to build up my views
so if you want to know about all the
stuff you guys are in the right place
so today i want to talk about a crazy
stuff that happened this week
with socket mobile guys the share just
sold 1 000 so this is insane
let's analyze this crazy move let's get
into it
[Music]
so socket mobile so all right market cap
80 million us dollars so it's very very
very small
the short interest is only one percent
once again guys to check the short
interest i go on
market bits all right market bit sorry
no s
and you just type for example here s
c k t socket mobile
all right and you have all the
information so 80 million
you tap short interest and you can see
that 0.9
once again i'm cross-checking this data
with bloomberg uh when i'm done using
google for these videos because i'm not
allowed
and this was published on the 29th of
january so two weeks ago so
uh it's maybe it has changed because now
the share has gone up 1000
so maybe things are different all right
and guys
uh the volume traded so i get the volume
here
on trading view you can have all the
stuff guys fx indicator you tab
type net volume you put it here so the
net volume is the number of shares so
200 million shares
uh that were traded at around 10
all right 13 10 so it's i don't know you
can put one you can put two let's put
1.5 all right
so it's around 20 times the market
capitalization
guys this is the big winner all right we
had
those crazy moves on cigarette the
woodstock sndl
uh gme amc uh it's below 1 000
for all of them all right so basically
there was a rush for this
so let's check the news what happened
here guys so basically
those guys socket mobile they are doing
some stuff
on mobile phones for more than 20 years
how
did it go definitely not good it was
worth 500
it went to one so basically guys it lost
compared to so this was the internet
bubble it lost
99.9
so guys this was not doing good for them
they had negative earnings for a very
long time and right now they did
something insane
stock mobile spikes 980
after announcing barcode scanner for all
iphone 12.
so basically you can use the scanner to
find information about the products you
buy you can buy directly
so basically it includes delivery
services
i'm not sure what it is uh stock
counting and ticketing alright so
basically
it's the future guys you can use your
phone to do all your stuff
and they uh created this stuff i think
they are the first ones to do so
and it's very interesting because once
again guys the short interest at one
percent
so it's very different from what we saw
on the other rally
this rally is natural guys and it's
beautiful to see that
this can still happen one thousand
percent only buyers it's not
short hedge funds that are cutting their
positions
all right it's natural buyers that just
came in in the game
together probably from reddit and all
these guys and you know the
money that they put two billion is the
usual amount they like to
you know put when they associate
together so if they keep doing this
and those guys they are not selling and
they are right because this is the
future i mean they're not always right
but in this situation
it's very good i think not to sell so
guys if they keep doing this
what is going to happen on this stuff
when you see the potential
when you see where it was ah guys it's
very nice so it went to 35 then it lost
a lot of value so right now what to do
guys if you are long
which i doubt holding it is a very good
strategy because the news are good
the earnings are probably going to come
back with this new stuff
and you have natural bias which is
better than uh you know
the growth is going to be sustainable
and sustained by those
natural uh buyers now if you're not long
yet
what can you do guys we do technical
analysis this is what i always do when i
need to find some entry levels all right
technical analysis is the framework that
you build
around your deeper analysis where you
use fundamentals use the market dynamics
this is what i was doing here i was
talking about hedge funds
the market cap showed interest trying to
understand the story behind
this move up so now that i get it now i
know
that i know that those uh this is coming
from natural buyers that just want to
believe in this new technology and
they're probably right to do so
i need to find an entry level all right
so an entry level would be you check the
last resistance all right this one is
very obvious guys so even if you're a
complete beginner
you can find this one all right and just
check the last maximum level which is
here
you can see that it acted here as well
as resistance
and you can see that it's roughly the
level
we had the gap up actually no the gap
occurred here sorry guys my bad
but this was actually a maximum level
just before the gap up
occurred and guys usually you see i can
check in the past all right so it's not
perfect i
agree but this was a support as well
here and almost here so this is in here
all right so this is the best uh support
or resistance level that you can find
and guys usually those stuff is retested
it doesn't take
one or you know less than one week all
the time sometimes it's going to take a
few weeks
be patient we have a lot of targets a
lot of opportunities guys this market is
full of opportunities
don't rush right don't buy it here this
wouldn't be smart you could make money
but this would be a lucky move guys
so if you want to trade like a pro
trader guys it's
entry level at a good level stop loss
and if it doesn't work you go to the
next one or you wait for another
opportunity to arrive
so here for example uh you can buy all
right so
i put it at the highest level so i'm not
missing this trade you can buy at 550
and then i check the lowest level where
i would put it i would put it here this
is too long you know this
if it was before i would put it here but
like this was like
guys 20 years ago we don't really care
so i put it
here all right and then do stop loss
just below that
all right so you stop loss here so you
buy 430 you stop loss at 350. so you can
lose 20
and how much you can win a few thousand
percent i mean the risk reward ratios on
this penny stocks are insane
but doesn't mean you need to play
without stop loss
you put a stop loss if it's not working
you wait for the next opportunity to
occur
and you play the next one all right guys
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video
i hope that you understood how to
associate
technical analysis with fundamental
analysis how to build up your view using
market dynamics
and you know everything that is actually
behind these strong
moves up and if you did please don't
forget to click the like subscribe
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show us you guys